[Music]
so my name is caroline hickman and i
want to talk to you about
talking about climate change and one of
the ways i want to do that
is by talking to climate change why
why do we want to do that well i think
one of the problems about climate change
is it's really really hard to imagine
if you're living in vanuatu living in
the maldives living in bangladesh
then we're seeing the immediate impact
of that but if you're living in europe
and you're living in the americas north
america in particular canada
then it is far from our immediate daily
concern
now if you're watching the television
you're online you're engaged you're
thinking about this
a lot which a lot of us are then we may
be thinking about this a great deal and
we might be having conversations with
each other about it
but a lot of people aren't and that's
one of the problems that we've got
in helping people start to engage with
climate change
now so what's our problem well one of
the problems
is that we've known about climate change
and we've known about what needed to be
done for decades
and we've not really acted on it we've
got technological solutions we've got
political
we've got economic arguments but we
still have a great
question mark about why we've not acted
on this
we've not got the same urgency around
climate and the biodiversity crisis as
we have about other
pandemic crises like the current virus
so why i'm a climate psychologist i
teach at the university
of balfour and i'm part of a group
called the climate psychology alliance
and what we want to do is bring a
psychological understanding
into thinking about why humans are not
responding with the urgency
that they need to to the climate and
biodiversity crisis
and yet of course some people are so
friday's for future greta tunberg
extinction rebellion
have been doing a fantastic job of
trying to change that story
and change that narrative but one of the
problems is is we get caught up
in a doom and gloom it's all terrible
it's all disastrous
argument versus oh no it'll be okay
the optimistic argument we can just
plant lots of trees or we can have
technological solutions
and we kind of bounce backwards and
forwards between the two
gus spare for climate scientists said
that he didn't think that technology was
the problem
with the climate change he thought that
we could easily find technological
solutions he said
that he thought the problems were
selfishness apathy
and greed now that's a very negative
approach to
human nature and human beings are
complex right we're very complex and
it's not
all destructiveness it's not all
negative and we've seen
with loving caring responses to
people around the world particularly at
the moment that actually things like a
crisis
globally can bring out both the worst in
people
but also maybe the best in people so
back to the psychology now i want to
tell you what
a child said so my research has been
primarily with children and young people
for five or six years now
and i want to tell you what one of the
children said when i started this
research because i think this would give
us some clues
i said to her well you know because i'm
a psychotherapist so it's not my
business to traumatize children and
terrified children
and yet i needed to find a way to talk
to them about frightening things
so obviously important one of the best
things to do with children and young
people is to ask them
one of the ways how can we talk with you
about this without scaring you
so i want to tell you what an
eight-year-old said to me she said well
she said you've got to tell me the truth
she said because if you don't tell me
the truth
about climate change she said you're
lying to me she said
and if you lie to me she said i won't
trust you
she said if i can't trust you then i
can't talk to you about things
i thought this was wisdom this was
genius from an eight-year-old
and then she followed it with and anyway
she said
i'm not a baby so part of the solution
in talking about climate change means
starting to uncover how we really feel
about it and it might also mean
that we have to search under the surface
of our barriers to climate change
we might have to accept the fact that
we're not entirely rational creatures
so first of all we want to go to
rational solutions about climate change
of course we do
and we want to talk about the science we
want to talk about the data and we want
to talk about
what would happen if we did this or we
did that
and i don't know about you but my head
spins when i look at the science
we are functionally psychologically
emotionally most of the time five
percent
conscious of what's going on now human
beings like to think that they're
rational creatures
but actually there's a heck of a lot
going on under the surface we're 95
unconscious i've got another image that
would help us think about
this we are largely unconscious so a lot
of what drives us
a lot of what makes us who we are as
humans a lot of
what would give us explanation about the
way we would approach things
particularly things that are threatening
and that's a risky is to look to the
unconscious mind
but when material from the unconscious
mind starts to bubble up into conscious
awareness
it scares us and it threatens us and we
defend against it
and that's when we hear the defenses
about climate change
we hear people go into climate denial
not what i think there's that much
climate denial around at the moment
i think for most people it's more of a
disavowal
what disavow looks like is on the one
hand you say yeah climate change is
really worrying it's really scary
and what are we going to do we've got to
do something particularly
when those images of the fires in
australia
and the destruction of the amazon
rainforest and the melting of the
glaciers
and the ice caps particularly when we
see that it brings into
conscious awareness and we start to feel
anxious and with there's been a lot of
discussion about eco anxiety and eco
grief
it pushes against our conscious
awareness and we get
really scared and we say yeah it's
really worrying
but then often we defend against that
with disavow and we say
oh it's really worrying but where are
you going on holiday this year
and oh but you know the government will
say this or science will say this or
technology will save us
something will happen to save us so we
move then into this sort of rescuer
fantasy
that either technology will save us or
economists will say this
one of the problems here is that there
is not a simple
solution searching outside yourselves
for the solution to climate change is
part of the problem
now part of the messaging has been well
we've got 12 years left to save the
planet it's less than that now of course
isn't it it's more like
10 or 9 or even less it's decreasing
because the messages we get all the time
is things are getting worse
it's hard to absorb this message it's
hard to make sense of it
we used to talk about it's five to
midnight actually now
groups of us are starting to say what if
it was five
past midnight what if it was too late to
actually
stop the worst impact of climate change
now i know
what that will do is trigger anxiety but
on the other hand if we don't start to
feel anxious we don't become aware
and if we don't become aware then we
don't care and if we don't care
then we don't take action so i want to
reframe this thing about this this
eco anxiety and start to call it eco
empathy that actually it's a sign that
we care
it's a sign that we're connected it's a
sign
of compassion and we need to move that
to a global empathy
so i've also been talking with children
in vanuatu the martial islands
bangladesh
and the maldives about this so my
question is is do we need to change this
story
and how can we change the story without
massively traumatizing people
because we need to take people with us
in this conversation
but we don't need to completely horrify
and overwhelm people
but on the other hand i'll tell you
what's a little bit more scary to me at
the moment
is this conversation about business as
usual
when we can go back to business when we
can get the economy
running again this is scary because
we are running out of time we need to
act and it's becoming
too late for billions of animals and
billions of people
so how do we find a way through this
well
back to the psychology so what i bring
to the table apart from
hopefully not scaring you too much i do
sometimes introduce myself in my talks
by saying
you know i am going to scare you but
stay with me to the end
because i'm going to show you what we
can do with some of that anxiety
what we need to do is get into those
feelings of course i'm going to say that
i'm a psychotherapist
but we need to know how to navigate
those feelings so that's some of the
work i've been doing
with artists and with storytellers and
with writers
and we've been doing that with children
and i want to show you a school project
that we did
so we wanted to talk with young children
and see if we could get them to imagine
climate change and we worked with a
group of children in wheelchair
and we worked with a artist friend of
mine called sonia shemaltsaday
now what sonja's been doing for years is
picking up sticks on beaches
and starting to draw and she does this
in a very imaginal creative
way and what she wanted to do was help
people start to see
and imagine the impact of something that
was too big to see
and this is what we think around climate
change it's almost too big to see
so it's too big to relate to it's what
timothy morton the philosopher calls a
hyper object
but what sonia does extraordinarily to
continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas